[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview la
crise du coronavirus s'aggrave en
amérique latine selon l'organisation
mondiale de la santé la majorité des
nouveaux cas de contamination ils sont
recensés et surtout au brésil où le
bilan fait état de près de quarante
mille morts particulièrement vulnérables
et les populations indigènes dans un
instant elle nous entendrons le
témoignage du chef indigène d'amazonie
ninawa mais avant cela
état des lieux avec vous régis le
sommier bonjour vous êtes journaliste
directeur adjoint de la rédaction de
paris match vous rentrez d'un reportage
au brésil vive inquiétude dans le pays
alors que les autorités font état de
plus de 770 milles contamination un
nombre de cadres de corona virus qui
selon les experts pourrait être jusqu'à
15 fois plus élevé en raison notamment
de l'absence de dépistage massif dans ce
pays qu'avez vous vu sur place quelle
est la situation racontez nous la
situation est effectivement assez
cataclysmique
il ya on a fait deux parties en fait
danse dans ce sujet on a d'abord
concentré notre travail sur sao paulo et
où là véritablement il ya treize mille
tombes dans le plus grand cimetière
d'amérique du sud la vie qui s'appelle
villa formosa treize mille tombes ont
été creusés en préparation en prévision
d'une accumulation d'une accroissement
considérable du nombre de morts là on a
assisté véritablement à des enterrements
à la chaîne c'est à dire que ces cinq
minutes par enterrement cinq personnes
maximum
l'élu la race de la famille restant à
l'extérieur du du cimetière donc ccd
scène absolument déchirante et avec une
vitesse une sorte d'empressement à
enterrer les morts dus qu'au guide et ce
qui est assez terrible aussi c'est que
évidemment les familles bas sont les
unes à côté des autres donc il n'y a pas
vraiment de de distanciation et ça c'est
un gros problème au brésil c'est à dire
que certains états ont propre rhône
justement le confinement
mais ce confinement on l'a vu un peu
partout et très peu respectés ensuite
nous sommes allés à manaus qui a été
particulièrement frappées par l'épidémie
pendant le mois d'avril au mois de mai
là des cimetières ont été taillées sur
la forêt tropicale
c'est à dire qu'ils avaient pas assez
place dans les cimetières locaux pour
pouvoir accueillir le nombre de morts et
on est là c'est une technique différente
c'est la technique des fosses communes
ouch chaque corps et intérêts là à côté
de l'autre six pieds sous terre c'est
des pelleteuses vie évidemment qui qui
font le travail est pareil avec une
vitesse une précipitation pour enterrer
le plus vite possible une véritable
psychose aussi en ville vous avez des
prédicateurs évangélistes qui vous font
des prières pour vous protéger
sur votre pub dans votre véhicule sur
mon sens vous toucher sans vous sans
avoir de contact vous avez des immenses
poster aussi en ville par exemple je
m'en souviens d'un en particulier où on
voyait une tombe
c'est une tombée à marquer vous allez
travailler sans masque reposez en paix
voilà donc c'est ce genre
d'avertissement mais quand on va dans
les favelas quand on va dans les
quartiers défavorisés
quand on va hélas dans les réserves
aussi indigènes puisqu'il y en a eu une
particulièrement qui s'appelle parquet
dos tribaux ce qui est juste à la sortie
de man de manaus vous avez 35 tribu des
représentants de 35 tribus qui vivent là
et bien les gens pratiquent peu les
masques un petit peu plus de masques
chez les indigènes parce qu'ils savent
qu'ils sont particulièrement à risque
mais dans les quartiers populaires
quasiment pas de masquer les
établissements sont censés être fermé
en fait on recrée le bar sur le trottoir
avec des gens qui sont torse nu en temps
etc et qui se touchent et qui sont les
uns à côté des autres sans absolument qu
une distanciation ce qui se passe avec
les indigènes et peut-être pire parce
que il ya des croyances autour des corps
il ya une sorte de sorte de malédiction
qui est lié à ce virus chez eux des
clients un mort parce que souvent bien
souvent malheureusement les gens n'ont
pas le temps d'aller dans les hôpitaux
et il le il meurt chez eux
et là on a assisté on a suivi des
ambulanciers comment un service de la
municipalité de manaus qui s'appelle sos
funeral et sos funeral va chez les gens
pour justement recueillir les corps et
chez les indigènes bien il ya une sorte
de peur
c'est à dire que dès qu'il ya un mort on
laisse le mort à la maison on s'enfuit
chez les voisins on se réfugie chez les
voisins et évidemment on contamine les
voisins il s'est passé aussi une autre
chose un autre phénomène qui est qu' un
certain nombre d'indigènes sont revenus
dans leur tribu par peur de ce qui se
passait à manaus en avril et en mai au
moment de la montée quasiment
foudroyante de l'épidémie ils ont décidé
d'aller se protéger ou ils ont cru aller
se protéger en retrouvant en retournant
dans leur communauté d'origine et bien
évidemment beaucoup d'entre eux ont
ramené le virus dans ces communautés et
aujourd'hui petit à petit le virus est
en train de remonter le rio negro qui
est l'un des gros affluent de l'amazone
l'amazone
enfin tous les cours d'eau jusqu'aux
frontières du pérou et de la colombie et
de se diffuser dans les petites
communautés
donc voilà il ya cet état sanitaire qui
est en train de s'aggraver
le virus qui frappe et les villes
jusqu'à présent a tendance à se diffuser
dans les campagnes il faut savoir
également que c'est un virus qui a
touché au départ les classes moyennes
voire les classes les plus favorisées et
qui est en train aujourd'hui de
descendre dans le peuple
on l'a constaté évidemment et
malheureusement les sept absolument
cette impossibilité ou presque de se
distancier de de respecter des normes
sanitaires est donc très difficile
d'endiguer le virus dans ces
circonstances là parce que parmi elles
et les plus atteints par la pandémie
aujourd'hui au brésil vous le rappeler
ce sont les populations indigènes
d'amazonie des populations très
vulnérable parce qu'elles ont une
immunité très basse comment est ce
qu'elle se soigne vous venez de
l'évoquer à l'instant mais est-ce
qu'elles vont à l'hôpital est ce
qu'elles sont re met essentiellement à
des traditions ancestrales quelle est la
part des deux finalement alors c'est
intéressant on a peur on of common
focaliser notre attention sur une
famille d'une tribu la tribu des mômes
de look ou qui était elle
dont les deux les deux parents ont été
frappés par le cos vide surtout le père
qui était sous respiration artificielle
pendant plusieurs jours dans un hôpital
on a pu le suivre à la sortie de
l'hôpital et ensuite on l'a retrouvé
chez lui alors évidemment et lui ce
qu'il a fait il est guéri soeur dans sa
tribu donc il s'en est remis au départ
aux médecines traditionnelles et une
infirmière un indigène justement qui a
commencé à prendre conscience de
l'importance de l'épidémie et des dégâts
qu'ils pouvaient proposer dans sa
communauté l'a convaincu à un moment
d'aller à l'hôpital de se faire soigner
parce que sinon son état empirait donc
il est allé à l'hôpital
comment le ce soit inutile aujourd'hui
avec de la chloroquine de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine et donc est couplé avec un
gentil un antibiotique
donc je lui ai demandé si il ressentait
des effets secondaires parce que ce sont
des médicaments à risque
il m'a dit vous savez les antipaludéens
moi j'ai attrapé 20 fois la malaria
gemain jeu comme beaucoup de gens
dansaient dans ces endroits là donc les
antipaludéens je maîtrise très très bien
les effets secondaires ça ne me fait
absolument pas peur et il m'a dit ça me
renforce physiquement j'ai vraiment eu
l'impression de m'en sortir grâce à
semer semaines ce médicament voilà donc
je n'ai pas avoir de preuve scientifique
je ne suis pas scientifique mais enfin
en tout cas les témoignages parce qu'il
n'ya pas que le sien que j'ai eu là bas
c'est évidemment essentiellement
traitement à base d'hydroquinone rodkin
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
le président brésilien g1 box narrow ni
la gravité la pandémie il fustige par
ailleurs les recommandations de l oms
sur les pas de son modèle américain
donald trump qu'ils menacent d'ailleurs
de quitter l'organisation mondiale de la
santé comment est-ce que ce déni se
manifeste-t-il dans la politique menée
dans le pays pour combattre le colis 19
alors faut il faut que considérait
d'ailleurs qu'un peu à l'image des états
unis que la structure politique du
brésil et fédéral donc il est du ressort
des gouverneurs de chaque état de
confiner ou non
de décider du confinement ou dur à
l'étang du ralentissement de l'économie
c'est ce qui a été décidé notamment par
joão d'aurillac et le gouverneur de sao
paulo qui est devenu évidemment
immédiatement la bête noire de bolton
arrow et de ses partisans parce qu'il
est accusé d' handicapé l'économie au
nom d'un virus qui finalement ne ferait
passer tant de dégâts que ça et c'est un
peu la croyance des bosses scénariste
sait que faire tout arrêter pour à cause
de ce virus et bien ça veut dire
torpiller le brésil ça veut dire aller
contre et ça veut dire appauvrir encore
plus la situation s'est un petit peu la
même chose qui a été pratiquée par par
donald trump sauf que peut-être que
donald trump n'a pas été aussi loin que
ball soir ou plutôt que bolt zone euro a
été encore plus excessifs que donald
trump dans cette espèce de véritable
mépris du virus jeu j'ai interviewé
justement une personne parce que ce
qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est que ce
virus au brésil frappe beaucoup de
jeunes il n'y a pas en france les la
proportion des morts je crois en dessous
de 44 ans dépasse et d'entre 200 ou 300
sur les 29 mille donc on a une très
petite petite quantité de personnes
entre 0 et 44 disons qu'ils meurent au
brésil c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose vous regardez les les dates tout
simplement sur les tombes et vous rendez
compte que vous avez beaucoup de gens de
30 35 ans qui décède et j'ai rencontré
un homme justement donc qui me semblait
avoir été ball sauna restée avoir changé
d'avis à propos du virus et qui m'a dit
moi et mon frère on a complètement
mépriser le virus on a fait comme si ça
n'existait pas et en mon frère est entré
à l'hôpital 20 jours plus tard elle
était mort donc il dit voilà je souhaite
au président brésilien
aujourd'hui de souffrir autant que je
souffre mois alors on sait que molson
arrow avec sa politique a connu des cas
de co vide
on dit que lui même l'aurait attrapée
même s'il n'y a pas eu de confirmation
en tout cas dans son entourage un
certain nombre de personnes ont été
contaminées
et c'est vrai que la façon dont il s'est
exprimé la façon dont il a négligé le
virus la façon dont il a continué à
tenir des meetings à faire du jet ski
comme si la vie elle n'avait pas changé
et bien à peut-être eu un impact
pourquoi parce qu' un certain nombre de
brésiliens faut le considérer
continue à suivre molson arrow qui reste
très populaire dans le pays
il a été élu c'est par un dictateur qui
est arrivé comme ça
exactement comme donald trump sauf qu'il
a eu lui le vote populaire à une très
large majorité et il reste encore
populaire et donc évidemment ces
agissements sa façon de se comporter par
rapport au virus a de l'impact auprès
des brésiliens dont certains croient dur
comme fer encore aujourd'hui qu'il faut
simplement faire comme si le virus
n'existait pas ou continuer à vivre
comme on le faisait avant et à
développer l'économie
ensuite après jeunes insiste sur le fait
qu'il n'y a pas que bolt sonar ou dans
cette histoire il ya aussi la façon dont
les brésiliens sont leur façon de vivre
là c'est impossible de confiner une
favela
c'est beaucoup trop étroit c'est voilà
et la question des masques et bien elle
n'est pas respectée il ya très peu de
gens qui ont des masques dans les
hôpitaux oui mais quand vous arrivez
chez les gens quand une personne est
décédée à son domicile
jamais une personne qui vous ouvre la
porte ne vous dira mon mari ou ma soeur
ou mon ma grand-mère est mort du co vide
non et c'est toujours mort de quelque
chose d'autre
en réalité c'est parfois des gens qui
avaient des pathologies antérieures
mais ce qui les a achevé ses biens virus
ça ça nous a été confirmée par les gens
des pompes funèbres confirmée par les
médecins
voilà il ya une sorte de malédiction
autour du virus très populaire et très
largement répandue un mois s'est
rapidement l'extension de la pandémie de
kobe 19 aggrave aussi cette autre menace
qui peuplent qui pèsent sur les peuples
indigènes celle de la déforestation elle
n'a cessé d'augmenter depuis l'arrivée
au pouvoir de jaillir bol sonar ou de
quelle façon
est ce que cette crise sanitaire à grave
ce problème en quelques mots elle
aggrave ce problème parce qu'elle
fragilise évidemment les communautés
indigènes
il ya eu des cas justement où même leur
territoire ont été il y a eu au moins
deux ans fin avril à manaus une pénurie
de cercueils n'avait pas assez de
cercueils qu'est ce qu'on a fait mais on
l'a pris sur les bois qui sont réservées
normalement protégé pour les indiens
d'amazonie reste une terre de deux
coupeurs de bois illégaux de où tout un
tas trafic a lieu et ça évidemment quand
les indiens sont fragilisés quand ils
sont frappés justement
ces pandémies ils ont tendance à ne vois
là à être encore plus vulnérable qu'il
l'était avant concentrés autour du virus
et et voilà et le phénomène vient
s'ajouter peut-être à leur malheur et
aux catastrophes qui ont été provoqués
justement par cette déforestation qui
continue elle n'a pas arrêté parce que
la pandémie ccc est très répandu tout ça
continue tout ce travail de grignotage
progressif de la forêt n'est pas encore
achevée et heureusement mais en tout cas
continuer à aggraver la situation dans
la forêt amazonienne
merci beaucoup registre le sommet je
renvoie votre reportage photo c'est à
dire dans paris match dans un instant
témoignage du chef indigène ninawa
depuis l'amazonie
c'est juste après une petite pause à
tout de suite
[Musique]
vous êtes dans la grande interview
émission consacrée à la situation au
brésil où le coronavirus ne cesse de se
propager l'épidémie s'attaque désormais
aux populations autochtones témoignage à
présent depuis l'amazonie du cacique
ninawa chef de la communauté unique oui
dans l'extrême nord-ouest du brésil
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui vous représentez cette
communauté de 15 mille membres répartis
en une centaine de villages qui vit dans
l'état de la cré frontalier du pérou
racontez-nous quelle est la situation de
votre peuple faso coronavirus j'ai
aujourd'hui dans l'état de la cre les
communautés unique hui sont directement
affectées par le corona vie revivre
nous avons à l'heure actuelle 64 unique
hui qui sont contaminés c'est un effet
de padt dans sept villages indigènes il
y à des personnes qui ressentent des
symptômes du coronavirus et jacques et
famous
nous recensons quelques morts et c'est
une communauté qui n'a toujours pas
d'assistance adéquates pour faire face
aux coronavirus quad à pau déphasé ou
qu'il s'agisse de prévention ou
d'assistance médicale aux personnes
affectées est alors comment est ce que
vous vous soignez ce que on entendait
certains témoignages de deux personnes
indigènes se rendant à l'hôpital dans
les villes escales anvers vous soigner
avec des des médications ancestrales
vous ne recevez aucun soutien de la part
de l'état et moi si nous ne recevons pas
d'assistance de qualité d' assistance
adéquate pour s'occuper des spécificités
culturelles et géographiques des
communautés et saudi ksar est pour ça qu
il existe des organes de santé qui sont
responsables de toutes les structures
mais ils n'ont pas les conditions pour
accéder aux communautés et n'arrive pas
à répondre à la hauteur de nos besoins
et à notre communauté travaille avec ce
qu'elle a utilisé les connaissances
traditionnelles
à travers la médecine ancestrale qui
existe dans la forêt amazonienne et
livres spirituels aussi et le guérisseur
de notre communauté travaille aussi à
l'aide du thé est travers la prière et
les chants sacrés pour pouvoir préserver
et protéger notre peuple est il protégé
de paul sackey élire mais le corona
virus est un virus qui touche et
contaminent le monde entier au tamil
nadu belles choses à vivre pour
contamination
c'est un virus qui se propage et la
plupart du temps ce certains indigènes
unique hui peuvent se soigner avec la
médecine traditionnelle
et ce n'est pas le cas de tous âges
certains ne peuvent pas recevoir ce
remède car ils sont plus fragilisée que
d'autres les âmes et des moeurs au hca
mais je doute et aux autres
vous savez il n'ya pas que l'outil les
plantes peuvent remplir aussi leur rôle
est soigné tous les contaminés de la
communauté une aiguille ici dans la zone
i dans l'état de la déco et vous besoin
aujourd'hui pour lutter contre la
propagation de l'épidémie ce qu'il vous
faut
plus de tests par exemple plus de tests
de dépistage nous emmène tôt pour le
moment comme je lui dis notre peuple est
affecté nous avons besoin de faire un
travail de prévention et pour cela nous
avons besoin de matériels et
d'équipements 0 à 100 par exemple du gel
hydroalcoolique du désinfectant du savon
des masques ce sont des ressources que
nous recherchons à avoir pour combattre
le corona virus tentons aussi de
communiquer via des brochures et des
supports audiovisuels
il sensibilise et notre communauté pour
ne pas qu'elles restent isolés pour ne
pas que les personnes est trop de
contacts rapprochés entre elle et
jackson nous avons lancé aussi une
campagne de fonds pour acheter des
aliments pour les personnes qui en ont
besoin pour aider à consolider leur
immunité
nous avons aussi besoin urgemment de
tests avec résultats rapides pour faire
une étude sur les communautés affectées
nous avons lancé cette campagne de
l'alliance des gardiens de la mère
nature avec l'aide de l'association
planète amazon qui se trouve à paris et
qui nous aident à récolter ces fonds et
pouvoir récupérer ce matériel de
protection et de prévention pour notre
communauté
comment réagir et les membres de votre
tribu face à l'arrivée du du cornât
virus comment a été comment est perçue
cette épidémie dans votre communauté et
moins tu as elle est d'ailleurs c'est ce
qui nous avons beaucoup de leaders des
leaders qui représente la communauté
uniquement aux espaces en se rendant
dans les villes ils ont compris que
cornaz virus était en train d'arriver
dans l'état de la cre nous avons
commencé avec une leader un travail de
prévention avec notre peuple
pour éviter les réunions éviter les
lieux de rassemblement de ne pas aller
en ville pendant cette période de
pandémie
malheureusement les équipes médicales
qui viennent de la ville ont fini par
amener au virus dans les communautés est
maintenant lié à 64 unique hui
contaminés vous êtes inquiet si on
imagine face aux conséquences de cette
crise sur votre peuple sur vos terres on
a entendu le chef raoni tenir des propos
très durs à l'égard de jallet humble
sonar au qui l'accusent de profiter de
la pandémie pour éliminer le peuple
indigène est ce que c'est votre
sentiment
ses amis opinium oui c'est mon opinion
c'est l'opinion de toutes les
communautés indigènes du brésil depuis
le début du mandat de jaillir banque
sonar au il a toujours essayé d'en finir
avec les droits des indigènes
il a tenté d'articuler les grands délits
jean et pour envahir les territoires
indigènes
amine el hassen mettre en place au sein
de nos petits villages
l'activité minière le pétrole les
barrages pour l'électricité
avec tout ça aujourd'hui le gouvernement
travaille fortement pour s'approprier
les territoires des peuples indigènes
pendant la pandémie il a utilisé
certains moments pour articuler cette
invasion par exemple le territoire des
yanomami où sont établis la plupart des
sites miniers illégaux
aujourd'hui cette communauté est en
danger à cause des personnes qui
travaillent sur ces sites et qui ont
amené cette pandémie
la même chose se passe dans toute
l'amazonie est dans état de l'âcre c'est
pareil l'amazonie est souvent présenté
comme comme le poumon de la planète mais
c'est c'est bien plus encore pour vous
quel est votre rapport à cette terre
sainte amène chez exactement l'amazonie
est considéré comme le poumon du monde
au québec parce que c'est là qu'on
arrive encore à faire tenir l'équilibré
environnemental et écologique sur cette
planète si amazonie disparaître nous
aussi nous disparaîtrons l'humanité
disparaîtra
ok notre relation avec la nature
nous peuple unique hui nous peuples
indigènes est une variation de respect
de mer à fils ok car sega nature qui
donne la vie c'est une relation
sentimentale spirituel ce n'est pas une
relation économique
une relation nous ne faisons que tirer
les ressources de la nature pour
survivre et pour nous le pétrole ou le
minerai ne sont pas des ressources
naturelles ce sont des entités sacré
avec des histoires sacré et millénaire
de nos ancêtres
c'est pour ça que nous donnerions notre
vie pour défendre d'amazonie nous la
défendons pour le futur nos futures
générations
mais c'est aussi pour l'humanité toute
entière que nous la défendons voilà la
relation que nous une aiguille et nous
peuples indigènes avant avec la nature
c'est une relation de respect de
protection d'amour voilà notre relation
à bord et mais comment est ce que vous
voyez l'après crise est-ce qu'il ya
quelques raisons d'espérer à pandémie la
pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
celles qui ont perdu un être cher qui
nous reviendra pas nous à travers nos
leaders spirituels sur nos territoires
nous utilisons nos techniques
médicinales mais nous prions pour
l'humanité toute entière pour protéger
les personnes qui souffrent à l'hôpital
pour leur trouver un remède est protégé
aussi les familles qui n'ont pas encore
été contaminée afin qu'elles soient
préservées
cela nous donne l'espoir et bientôt
cette pandémie sera vaincu et que la
paix et l'harmonie règne rond et
reviendrons dans nos foyers où
travaillent dans les familles cette
pandémie met en lumière un moment de
notre vie où un message doit être passé
aux familles elles peuvent être plus
unis arrêter un peu cette accélération
pour l'économie pour le développement
global du car nous avons besoin aussi
être en paix et en harmonie il s'agit
d'un moment on stagne où il s'arrête
avant de reprendre une vie normale et
c'est une alerte pour que les gens
puissent comprendre qu'après cette
pandémie mais on surgir d'autres une
pandémie émotionnel ce qui s'est isolé
qui vivent seules sans contact ceux qui
sont affectés psychologiquement il y
aura certainement d'autres moments
d'autres pandémies et il faut se
préparer pour cette nouvelle étape est
ce que vous avez peut-être un message à
faire passer pour les français notamment
qui vous regardent aujourd'hui comment
est ce qu'on peut vous venir en aide
c'est et c'est très important pour le
peuple français pour ceux du monde
entier
nous vivons un moment délicat est triste
et nous devons être solidaires les uns
avec les autres a sous les tables ou sco
saute c'est le moment de nous donner la
main pour combattre la pandémie du
coronavirus comme je les dis on meurt à
l'oeil
nous avons mis en place une récolte de
fonds pour obtenir du matériel de
prévention et de protection des aliments
pour ceux qui en ont besoin de l'eau
potable est aussi pouvoir produire du
matériel éducatif pour sensibiliser
notre communauté nous avons besoin de
faire face à ce coronavirus comme si
c'était une maladie très grave comme une
maladie qui apporte beaucoup de douleur
dans nos familles nous allons rénover
l'amour dans notre coeur que nous avons
les uns pour les autres
nous allons d accélérer et porté notre
attention sur notre vie sociale
nos familles nos enfants nos familles
qui sont loin
car nous avons besoin de ce moment de
solidarité d'avoir plus d'amour dans
notre coeur plus de compréhension et
d'attention envers notre prochain aimer
notre prochain et je remercie à chaque
français qui peut nous aider à appuyer
cette collecte de fonds et tous les
autres peuples du monde qui souffre et
est pas belle du monde
voici mon message aimons nous les uns
les autres et nous mêmes ce que nous
disons aujourd'hui et bibliques
soyons solidaires les uns envers les
autres et cela car cela nous aide
beaucoup fait sur les balles ou par la
conso et ici nous et il faut prendre
conscience en france qu'il faut se
protéger comme partout dans le monde
un très grand merci pour votre
témoignage toutes les informations
utiles à retrouver sur notre site
internet pour venir en aide aux
populations indigènes merci à vous de
nous avoir suivi cette grande interview
est à retrouver sur notre site
rt france pont tva plus tard
[Musique]